you're right and i think
we can also lighten the mood a little
bit by giving a good example
of bad leadership and what happens when
you have a population that just blindly
marches behind blind leadership and
refuses to accept it
we have a series of stories actually the
first of which is that ron desantis
said to joe biden i don't want to hear a
blip out of you until you secure the
border because he accused joe biden
of importing the virus what is it like
seven thousand
uh seven thousand in macau in texas
tested positive i believe
and joe biden migrated this is the
craziest thing biden's like we're going
to require
all foreign visitors to be vaccinated
but illegal immigrants it's optional
i'm not kidding literally they're like
we'll offer it to you if you want it but
1.2 million people
so so joe biden responds saying governor
who
and ron desantis had the best comeback
is it because i don't forgot who i am i
don't think that's what i would have hit
him with
he said what else has he forgotten oh
i remember obama making fun of trump
this way
just this dismissive like yeah who does
he that guy's nobody
he will never he's like fortunately i
will be remembered as a president
you remember that and then you're
missing them uh i'll be remembered
i'll uh be remembered as president
yeah just and now there's a really funny
article it was like it was from the
independent ron desantis's popularity
plummets after joe biden says governor
blue and i'm like
no we didn't where are they getting that
well no no
it's a spurious correlation it's like
his approval rating goes down because of
covet in florida or something
and then biden says governor who and
they they swallowed spurious
correlations do you think
anyone who likes ron desantis was like
joe
biden just eviscerated
this is just like when trump told
hillary she'd be in shout outs
i just can't believe that biden like
especially when this is someone who
actually probably did forget who he was
biden wasn't even trying to slam him
uh the samples uh we got harry laird
corn pop gordon pop check it out check
us out check us out from timcast.com
biden says 350 million americans have
been vaccinated
more than u.s population what i what i
love the most
i thought we were up to 370. i thought
we went what 337. you know what i you
know what i really love about
teamcast.com is uh uh
you know we're we're doing our best not
always wrong but this title is perfect
we don't snark we're not making fun of
them we're literally just
stating the fact biden says 350 million
americans have been vaccinated comma
more than u.s population we don't need
to explain
anything else the news it's right there
it speaks for itself our our uh
nonpartisan factual ban i was gonna say
our president ain't there dude no he's
really not
well at least we're laughing huh yeah
man that's one lighter story
gallows humor yeah well but what do we
do when you also like a genuinely evil
human being
you guys should read biden inc from
politico where they're like conveniently
when joe biden was put in charge of iraq
his brother got all the contracts for
building things there
hold on that's an unverified conspiracy
theory from politico.com
unverified conspiracy website oh yeah i
love i love it yeah
they are i mean politico reported that
uh ukrainians were scrambling after they
had tried to help hillary clinton in the
election
and you know interfering and a court
ruled as such and then later politico
reported
never happened there was no interference
and i'm like political retract your
story but they would they had both
simultaneously running it was
it was it was beautiful it's a beautiful
paradox of fake news
yeah politico is funny earlier i was
reading an article on the biden
administration repealing the trump era
rules against federal funding going
towards research done on unborn children
who were killed in abortion
and the article described the trump
regulations is very strict
and these very strict trump era
regulations are being unwinded by joe
biden like okay
he should just let him kill a little bit
yeah
we're never gonna do human
experimentation right never
just kind of grabbed like a thumb
the idea is that people are going to get
abortions so you may as well
use that's what we were saying basically
look at all the the fetal tissue that
one's at 42 weeks i mean it's a living
baby but
oh wow remember remember that south park
episode where uh christopher reeves
was yeah i don't remember that one so so
uh in the episode
christopher reeves again is in a
wheelchair and then he takes a baby and
he cracks it open and then he
sucks it dry and then he stands up from
his wheelchair
the south park guys are are brilliantly
funny
the issue was though they were mocking
the ideas if it didn't happen
as if this look obviously christopher
reeves never did that
there's nobody who's literally taking
the babies and cracking them open but
it's it's it's an analogy i suppose
i guess they were exaggerating for
humor's sake but we see these stories
since 2015. well and also i mean there
you can do stem cell research without
killing unborn children there are i mean
the umbilical cord is rich in stem cells
there are also stem cells that they've
been able to extract from adults and
they tend to be more effective in
experiments than the ones that are
coming from children
they're killing i'm gonna tell you man
when once we get into the ai
era all sense of human decency is gone
you think you're past that point man no
no no no no no no
here's the thing we're like here's the
thing we're decent to humans who are
interfacing with
right but as soon as someone's out of
our space we don't care we're complete
sociopaths
a robot is going to treat a human like
we would elaborate also
when the ai when the ai comes in and you
get like an ultron
or whatever look at what they do we
talked a lot about china right
how they just will bulldoze homes
because like you don't own it anyway
it's a lease
there's no eminent domain there they
just do whatever they want so we had
jack basobic telling us how like you
know the
the democrats or the you know the us
politicians go over there and they're
like you can just basically
crush an entire residential neighborhood
and build a highway and they're like yup
we're not even at that level in the
united states necessarily we have like
oh well there's a lawsuit in the
constitution an eminent domain the fifth
amendment you've got to pay you know et
cetera
yeah once you get to the ai er level
they're going to be like the robot's
going to just
in the in the flash in the blink of an
eye be like we need
you know 5 000 living adult humans to
figure out
what how x does why or something and
there will be literal people just
completely treated like
cabbage garbage do you think we're going
to get to that point with ai though
you guys should because moore's law has
been slowing down read which one the
artilect wore by hugo de garis yeah it's
my favorite book in the whole world
isn't that like a really hard to get
book or something
uh yeah it's like a thousand dollars on
amazon i will let you borrow my copy
don't you yeah that's like a third the
price of a text book
yeah that's pretty good yeah but it's
it's written
it's a really interesting book this guy
um
actually is pro robot takeover but he
does present both sides very well um and
they call it the art elect war or it'll
be like
pro robot table so you guys so you guys
really do
get to that point oh yeah yeah yeah
probably yeah but more
than slowing down for all you know no
has it no they've started doubling
about this i mean yeah these are
doubling up chords what what chords have
been scores scores they start doubling
up cores and processors oh yeah yeah
once once
64 core is that available right now once
once yeah
so once once we hit the like moore's law
was like oh it's you know every two
years it doubles yeah
and then they're like oh no the the it's
it you know everything's getting too
small and the electrons are popping in
and out
they just start adding up more they're
also moving away from using electricity
and
and shifting the light in in circuitry
or quantum computing
yeah so also this assumes that civil
society exists long enough for ai to be
developed it's going to be they're going
to be paying women to get pregnant and
just be there
and giving birth over and over and over
that'll be their job
i don't think yeah if there's an ai in
charge it will be harvesting humans
no we we've talked about this foreign
humans
so there will be untold cruelty because
cruelty doesn't exist in the mind of the
machine trying to find the most
efficient end
but a lot of what would happen this is
nightmarish so first we talked about
algorithmic psychosis on this channel
quite a bit
how people go on social media and then
just get fed a
rotating cycle of insane content which
makes them go insane over a certain
amount of time
what people don't realize you really got
to look at how ais develop things
they don't do exactly what you intend
them to youtube
so so that's true but to be fair ai and
algorithms are fairly different but just
for rudimentary's
argument youtube says here are the
parameters by which
we want this system to feed content to
people and what they were hoping for was
game of thrones
longer form content with high engagement
what do they get they got
the incredible hulk and hitler doing tai
chi and hitler's head was on a bikini
body and it's singing in nursery rhymes
okay but to be fair i wouldn't that's
don't belittle that compared to the
avengers all right bro like that's
really elitist of you to say one is
better than the other oh
oh for sure but here's what i'm saying
really awesome apply that principle
to an algorithmically run society in any
capacity or an ai that is incred
exponentially developing what will
happen is it's it's
will have nothing but corn and then one
day all of a sudden like everything in
the supermarket is just corn and you're
like
why where's the milk where's it it just
corn replaces everything
because the ai was like corns faster and
easier to make and if we make more of it
it's easier to make more
at one time and then all of a sudden you
have no resources everyone starves well
i mean so
the problem with ai theoretically would
be the same problem that we have with
anything humans construct whether it's
an algorithm whether it's public policy
there are laws there's the law of
unattended consequences
anytime humans try to set up a structure
to get a certain kind of behavior
from a person or a group of people they
end up with something other than what
they were shooting for sometimes it's
successful but i'm not sure if you've
heard of the cobra effect or if i've
ever talked about this on the show
so there was i can't even remember the
country i actually i believe this was
in british occupied india and there were
cobra
infestations and so what they did was
they said we will pay people for every
cobra tell that they bring us because
then they'll be out there killing cobras
they have an economic incentive to do so
they'll bring the carcasses to us we'll
give them money what happened was people
started finding male and female cobras
and starting breeding operations
so they could kill the cobras bring them
to the british government and get money
and so the population of cobras
increased
there's a there's a story i was reading
on reddit and they said that they pro
they programmed an ai to play tetris
hoping to see
highest level play like level 100 it's
going so fast you can't even see the
screen
you know what the ai did just quit got
bored and started playing
goal the goal was to see to generate an
ai that could play tetris for as long as
possible
so what do you think it did pause the
game yes oh my gosh that's whole
game path of least resistance that's
right and so we're thinking it's going
to play and then alternate pauses and
we're like wait what
oh man we got to change that so i'll
tell you this
i think we've talked about the ai future
where i've said like
you know you'll wake up and your phone
will vibrate and it'll be like
free credit opportunity and it'll say
walk outside and yell
and then you'll you'll be like okay
you'll go outside and you'll yell and
then it'll go accomplished
and then it'll give you credits and then
there'll be another guy walking on the
street i'll be like turn left here
and you know uh uh pic pic pick up this
this strange object
from this man and you'll walk by and
you'll see the guy in this picture and
i'll hand you a weird black orb and
you'll go
okay and then it'll say now walk three
feet hand it to the woman and you do but
then you get credits
because what's happening is wherever you
are and you're walking the ai has found
a method of delivering that object that
it needs to a certain area faster than
you just going and doing it
so you're getting these random
instructions you don't quite understand
the scary thing is eventually someone's
going to get one that's going to be like
turn left here and they're going to fall
off a cliff
and then they're gonna into the ground
and holding the orb and then someone
walks up and picks up the orb from the
carcass and walks away
because the air doesn't value you as an
individual
yeah ai future man what if they code in
what if they put if
going to have someone walk off building
then stop remember when apple maps came
out
some lady drove into a lake because
apparently she oh my gosh that's
right she was driving throwback she was
driving on the road and it said turn
left here and she went
okay it's like that episode of the
office do you remember that no
when michael drives into the lake i
think the gps tells him too there was a
that's probably where they got a true
story there was one lady who drove like
500 miles into the desert
because it told her to turn right here
and she did and then she ran out of
and she's in the middle of nowhere like
i don't know where i am and because the
computer told her to do it she did it
that siri didn't like how she was
talking
she's like i know what i'm doing can i
just stress this is gps
this is not even like something running
your life
it's literally just a map you can look
at and be like that's bringing me to the
desert i'm not going to go there and
people still do it
yeah man what do you think is going to
happen when we start getting more and
more robots to replace more and more of
our lives dude i had my gps recently
tell me to take a u-turn immediately
after merging onto the highway when
there was
when there was a barrier between the
sides of the highway
that you can drive on so like literally
it was just telling me to kill myself
people doing it people do this pretty
rude it's gonna be
uh unfun but uh and then you know what's
the best part i just went onto the
highway normal like and then in order to
get me off the highway and turn around
it like specifically had me go through
two tolls that's rude
i'm starting to think this is on purpose
man see that's the other thing too
does your gps ever do weird stuff with
tolls yes i've had other people share
similar stories
i don't i don't i don't know if it's
intentional but it's you seamus that's
probably sorry
we gotta make sure ai stays as advisors
and not as commanders
it's too late bro i don't i don't know
we've already got computer programs that
that tell us what to do with our with
our day
think about how much i got to watch
sometimes i'm wearing the watch
and then in the middle of the day it'll
vibrate and then it's a little man who's
like middle
middle age like a middle-aged kind of
tubby guy and he's like doing like
you know this or whatever and going like
that and it's like time to get up and
i'm like and tim literally does exactly
that
i literally does that little movie i
seen it happen it's crazy it's great
it's like i get loving
response true the little man says it's
time to start moving and i get up and i
walk around and i go outside and then it
gives me a little thing
i get an award i actually downloaded the
footage of the little guy doing that and
whenever i play it tim
just involuntarily starts doing the
workout he's been so conditioned well
because the watch says i have to do it
yeah no you have to you can't not listen
to the watch i don't know i think
we'll have to make sure that following
ai instructions gives you reward
incentives as opposed to punishment for
disobeying
well but i think that when we're done
exactly
yeah thank you yeah it's i think it's
more in cities you trust it more when
it's just a reward brave new world
versus absolutely yeah back to you yeah
do you want your
do you want your happiness medicine or
your video game much rather happy have
the happiness medicine this is what
that's what you're getting right now
i know when you're when you're staring
at your phone you're getting those
dopamine hits you're seeing the likes
and the retweets and you're like oh man
you got to break that spell man
it's here no i'm just like i am the
first to admit i have a problem with it
it's difficult when you make any of your
living on social media you have this
justification for looking at it and
engaging with your audience
but it's really easy to justify an
addiction that way there's a really
simple way to break the addiction to
likes and views and retweets
you just need to have several million
followers get over 100 million views in
a single exactly once i get there
once but no no but in all honestly once
there's nowhere left to go
you lose all reward triggering from the
entire system
and you lose any and all emotion related
to any of it
that's what i'm hoping for to just lose
all of my emotions
but no i i hear you like i feel like if
you hit a plateau that's sort of what
happens
it's not it's not a plateau it's like
when you when you've climbed the top of
the highest mountain what do you do next
you know eventually just like well that
was fun you know
we see all right but here's what i would
like i know knowing myself
i would try to expand in other things
because you know i'm already doing that
i work with other clients i try to
produce videos from different
organizations so i'll always be like i
have to
keep sure what i'm saying is most people
on uh on youtube there's a youtube
depression thing that happens because
views are seasonal especially food for a
show like so true
yeah politics they are so we're we're a
news policy i think this is actually
tim cassarella's society and culture but
uh tim
tim pool daily show is news so views go
way down
and everyone right now is like ha ha
cnn's viewership is in the gutter and
i'm like yeah but i'm like it's not
that's not funny guys
well no no cnn's general knew so their
views shouldn't be this bad but brian
stelter's like checking he's like
refreshing yeah they couldn't break a
million youtube stuff they couldn't get
cnn couldn't break a million views
that's right or whatever
so the point is but it wore in the down
season there's no election this year
there's no primary
so next year's election things start
kicking back up but what happens to a
lot of these youtubers
is they notice their views are going
down they have panic attacks they start
freaking out like why are my numbers low
this is bad and they feel like they're
losing because they don't understand
break the spell dude it's not real no
that's true that's right i've gotten
better at that because they're
like over the past year especially i
feel like i've had a lot of like
it is a weird way of putting it but
steady ups and downs it hasn't been all
over the place but it's like oh we're
doing really good and then oh not so
good and then really good again
and so it's gotten to the point where i
don't worry about it too much but i
think it has to happen to you
it has to happen to you enough to the
point where you know not to be concerned
when you're in those dips
we just need to educate kids about this
stuff before they get into it yeah
well yeah a couple years ago it was like
in may
and i put up a video and the views were
just in the gutter and i was like did i
do something wrong
maybe it was bad for me too is is the
video not entertaining like what's
happening and i was like well i'll tell
you what
you can't win them all right so so i'm
like you know what i did my best i i
shot my shot and
i'll just keep working tomorrow and i
don't let the little things hold me up
went out to eat and all of a sudden
we went out everywhere we went was
packed every restaurant
every diner and i was like guys get back
inside and watch my
videos that you're exactly right they
were outside yeah and so then i thought
about it and i looked up it had been
raining the entire week
and so everybody was inside watching
you're watching your videos your views
are good
and then the sunny spring day happens
and all of the families wanted to go out
to eat in the nice weather
that's what they're not as about to
watch videos the song where i come from
rain is a good thing
it's about a youtuber when people are
inside watching the videos are working
oh sorry no good i i just want to
mention one more thing because
it's on this topic we have not you
mentioned we should be teaching kids
about this stuff
and it's so crazy because we have no
idea how to navigate social
media in a truly healthy way and it's
not just social media it's instant
connection and communication so i was
thinking about this a while ago
if you had some kind of universal pa
system
in cars the way truckers have them where
you can just communicate with other
truckers
people would immediately start killing
each other road wage would get horrible
like if people no no no hold on this
this exists i know tesla's starting to
no no no
no it's it's like ancient technology bro
no no that's what i'm saying they could
do it very easily no no no no no no no
no
no
you're talking about ancient technology
a powerful enough broadcaster will
will will broadcast sound from any
speaker yeah yeah
again you can literally uh if you have
the broadcaster i'm pretty sure that's
illegal to do so don't do it yeah but if
you had a powerful broadcaster you could
literally pull up next to a car and
broadcast through their speakers where
they wanted you why did you
not it's not an issue of frequencies or
radios or anything
it's that the signal hits the speaker
itself and sends the sound out my point
is tesla's
talked about implementing this with
tesla and truckers have it oh yeah the
infrastructure for actually talking with
the other cars on the road next year
it's part of the status quo you're not
doing anything illegal
we don't do this and i suspect part of
it is because that would distract
drivers and it would also be
horrific in terms of road rage you think
about the way people talk to each other
on the internet when they think they're
anonymous
imagine when you're on the highway with
people you never think you're going to
see again i think it would cause a lot
of problems and that's a relatively
simple technology
you look at social media and how much
that's affected us the fact that we were
completely unprepared for it and it was
just dropped on us
we have no rules for it i i want to say
i feel really bad for kids today you
know why yes
they'll never know the joy of rushing
full speed to the wall-mounted phone as
you race your siblings to try and answer
it first
because you want to know who's calling
mm-hmm
when it rings and then it's your brother
or sister who answers it you're like who
is it what is it and it's like
it's like the bank calling and like who
cares they're asking if i have time to
take a survey
now to be fair when you have like
youtube tv or one of these networks like
you still
run the bathroom the commercial comes on
yeah for sure but i guess
the other thing i wanted to mention is
it's not even just social media you look
at the instant communication that we
have with our cell phones
sms you have an obligation to upkeep
relationships with people when you're
not even seeing them that day people
will be upset with you for not texting
them back quickly enough
in the past it was completely normal to
go a day or two without having
conversations with people
you were close to but now it's constant
and people will even be upset
if you're not giving them space in your
life and attention
when you're not with them that day you
know you so you know
ian i'm sure everybody here understands
this i remember it's like i'm a little
kid
and i'm going to my friend's house going
to go see if they're home
walk across the alley because we know
our friend lives on the other on the
next street over so we walk through the
alley go to the house knock on the door
there's no answer and i go i guess i'm
not gonna hang out with him today
and that was it yeah and then and
someday some days i'd answer
and and my friend's mom would answer and
i'd be like you know is my friend home
she'd be like oh he's uh he's at the
park
oh i'm gonna go to the park and i go
there no one's there and then i'm like
nobody's here i got them at the park now
by myself
that was it that was life no cell phones
i caught the very tail end of that like
i you know i didn't have a cell phone as
a kid or anything like that
it wasn't until high school but i'm
adventures dude yeah i remember when i
was a kid just like going out to my my
friend's house or calling them on the
landline asking their parents if they
were home it's like dr manhattan
you know in in watchmen when uh he's
he's he's at the final antarctic
fortress or whatever and ozzie mendius
has been sending tachyons
to obstruct dr manhattan's future site
and then he says you know he's like i
want to thank you i'd almost
forgotten the joy of not knowing bro
before the internet before
cell phones life was an adventure you
didn't know where you were going or why
you were going there
we'd like walk down the old freight
tracks and then find like an old
abandoned shipping yeah
i don't know what it is now it's like
the map just shows you the whole time
and you're like i knew that was there
it's not fun
yeah no i missed no adventure i missed
it but i'm sorry cassandra you were
going to say something
oh it's okay it's not relevant anymore
just say it i want to hear it it's okay
are you sure yeah okay when did you get
internet for the first time
um i had it in elementary school at my
grandparents house i would go on aol
dial-up oh my god my favorite noise yeah
yeah good computers
bro we had compuserve too on das not on
dos yeah bro
what did you what do you know nothing
nothing i i settled
my my asian family was very
technologically advanced i see that yeah
yes well let me tell you about my irish
family
not super technology yeah okay i thought
you were gonna say something else
very technologically advanced what do
you think i was gonna say some kind of
offensive stereotype i'll have none
[Applause]
i thought you were gonna say that your
family were prestigious
and uh well-renowned distillers of fine
yeah
whiskeys not drunks at all excuse me tim
that's
exciting i'm also irish that's yeah he
can make some of these jokes i guess
i like that i like that family guy but
your passing is not irish you know so
like you don't understand the oppression
like the family guy joke where it's like
he land that the plane lands in ireland
and there's beer bottles
in the runway and then he says something
like you know ireland
he's like ireland was a very different
place before the invention of alcohol
and then it flashes back to like but
it's actually a futuristic society with
flying cars
yeah and scientist comes in and he's
like look they invented out whiskey
and they all started beating each other
up yeah i guess it's not true though the
the stereotype of irishes being drunk
has never been true that's never been
true it was a propaganda thing
i promise i've never even met i've never
met an irish person with a drinking
problem once
it's traveling there not one of them
lying i've never met an irish person who
bs
either tim never it's not even a thing
i don't dude i'm going to be honest
there's a lot of truth to that
stereotype
there's a lot of truth to the stereotype
of irish people drinking a lot
i gotta be real the paddy wagon i don't
i don't know what pc nonsense you've
been hearing but it's
it's a thing it is thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you